il faut qu'à côté on fasse tout un tas
de choses qu'on n'a toujours pas fait il
faut par exemple augmenter nos capacités
hospitalières
parce que on ne peut pas simplement
faire porter l'effort sur les français
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et la
vaccination des soignants en attend
toujours
il yal isolement des gens positifs dans
des hôtels à faya il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses à faire et pas
seulement profil mans en tout cas ce qui
est très étonnant c'est qu'on en soit
disserter sur ce sujet alors qu'on a des
confiner le 11 mai il rêve quand même je
crois fallu se préparer depuis bien plus
longtemps s'ils ont l'impression de
subir sans que jamais l'exécutif n'ait à
coude avance s'ils ont l'impression
qu'en fait les gens au volant ne sont
débordés en permanence là la confiance
aura du mal être retisser et mon
inquiétude c'est que il ya une crise de
désobéissance civile qui apparaissent du
temps nous n'étions pas prêts au mois de
mars et on pouvait imaginer que ce
puisse être le cas partout puisque tout
le monde a été surpris au tour moi je ne
comprends pas pourquoi nous ne sommes
pas prêts pour cette deuxième vague
ça fait des mois qu'on dit qu'il faut se
préparer et nous manifestons je crains
que rien n'était fait d'abord quand
c'est la guerre on donne un fusil à
l'instituteur et on lui apprend à être
combattants bien puisque le président de
la république nous a dit que c'était la
guerre
moi je le prends au mot et je pense
qu'il faut confort massivement des gens
n'ont pas soigner les patients ils sont
pas médecin mais qu'on puisse fermer des
gens à nous aider à des tâches peu
spécialisés donner à manger tenir
compagnie par exemple dans les ehpad
c'est un élément important
déjà en forme tous ces gens là ensuite
les aides soignants on prend quelques
aides soignants volontaires ont le léon
les autres grades sur deux ou trois
tâches très précises pour qu'ils
puissent faire comme des infirmiers sur
deux ou trois tâches
entendons nous on ne forme pas d
affirmer en trois semaines des
aides-soignants on les autres grades
pareil des infirmiers sur des tâches que
l'on confié aux internes y voyez on a
une on a une vision très pragmatique des
choses la même manière on regarde tous
les médecins et infirmières qui ont une
expérience relativement récent de la
réanimation et qui n'en font plus on les
remet à niveau et on leur confie non pas
une réanimation mais on les met on les
intègre dans les équipes de réanimation
pour renforcer celle ci si on se
contente de faire avec les moyens
habituels
par définition on aura beaucoup de mal à
y arriver